نفق على مؤخرة الرأس من ظروف النظام الغذائي
فرع صب صنع برلين و
فيمو هنا هو عارضته العبادي ذات الشعر الرمادي و
نقل البرسيم
يمكن حتى 40 امرأة حتى muon bah الصلاة إلى الجحيم
أنت هنا lm سوف يفكرون في الفحم
و
عرض هذا الشريط الذي ستجمعه سارة بنفسها
برلين تتنفسني من العمل x منفردًا
لكنه حصل على الكلمة في الفوج عند 43
فوج الكشاف الذي تم تكليفي به
منصب زعيم الفصيلة
أضواء كاشفة و 700 مليون شمعة
هناك قوس فولتية خاص محترق
الفحم
مصباح خاص هو محور هذا الضوء
تنعكس على العاكس وبعيدًا عن العاكس
كان الهواء يغادر هناك بالفعل ، وكنا بمفردنا
ذهب إلى هناك لألمانيا توقف في
مدينة صغيرة
ثم كان فينيكس والدو الكتيبة 26
كتيبة كشاف منفصلة
كشاف مدفعية كتيبة
ركلات بقعة ضوء
بلغت لتوها حوالي 43
الكشافات
كان ذلك يوم 16 أبريل
في مكان ما حوالي الساعة الرابعة أو
هناك حوالي أربعة وبدأت
إعداد المدفعية لأن كاي
الرعد الذي لم يسمع غيره
كانوا يطلقون النار من خلال وقوفنا خلفي
قواطع محملة كاتيوشا
أضاءت وبدأت القيادة هكذا
أتمنى له المخاط تحت تكلم الجنود
لذلك مجرد البحث والشراء و
ثم لا يمكنك رؤية الساعة
أعمى لكم هنا في فصل منفصل من الجنرالات
ذكرت الألمانية اعتراض مكان ما
ذكرت برلين أن الروس
تطبق نوعا من الضوء ، أو الكيمياء ، أو
هل هناك أي شيء آخر من هذا القبيل لأنه جدا
مشرق انه بدأ يقول
حول الأضواء كيف أعموا رجال الشرطة
الناس مثل الجد وكل من خاض الحرب
لقد قادوا رفاقهم للموت
العائلة ولديهم بالفعل فكرة مختلفة عن
الحياة والموت قد رأوا الكثير بالفعل
لذلك أعتقد أنهم كذلك
البعض الآخر مختلف جدًا مقارنة بهم
الأقران
بشكل عام ، الجيل الحديث هؤلاء الناس
فهي مختلفة جدا
حظيرة أجداد أحد تقريبًا و
الجدات الذين كانوا لنا كذلك
يبدو لي أنهم لا يعرفون أقل من ذلك بقليل هنا
لأن ما يقولونه في المدرسة
سواء كان مكتوبًا في الكتب فهذا ليس كثيرًا
يكفي عندما نمت كازاني وأكثر
مفهوم كل شيء أفضل ممكن
شعور
[موسيقى]